ما الذي نعرفه أكثر عن الأصول
التي تم استخدامها أه في هذه الضربات اليوم
على حد علمنا الآن أحد
الأصول ومن أهم
الأصول هو fa18 Hornet هذا هو حقا أه العلم
أه السفينة إذا صح التعبير  من
حيث الطائرات المقاتلة للبحرية الأمريكية أه
فهي طائرة ذات قدرة 1.8 ماخ أه
ويمكن أن يكون لديها القدرة على التزود بالوقود الجوي
ولديها صواريخ موجهة دقيقة
وهي مهمة حقًا
ولديها أيضًا مدفع 20 ملم ويمكنها التعامل مع كل
هذه أه  أنواع مختلفة من الأسلحة
بما في ذلك القنابل الموجهة بالليزر المعروفة باسم
أسلحة الهلام والمربى وذخائر الهجوم المباشر المشترك
ويمكن استخدامها ليس فقط
للدوريات الجوية القتالية ولكن أيضًا
للهجوم البري وهذا بالضبط ما
فعله نظام الأسلحة هذا في
هذه الهجمات في اليمن والعقيد  كما
كان أورين يشير للتو إلى أن الولايات المتحدة
توضح للبنتاغون أن
وزير الدفاع يقول أن هذه مجرد
بداية لهذا الرد أه فماذا
نعرف أكثر عن الوجود الأمريكي
الوجود العسكري في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط
نعم هكذا  فيما يتعلق
بالوجود العسكري الأمريكي في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط
أه، فنحن منتشرون بشكل أساسي
في جميع هذه المناطق هنا، لذا فإن
أحد الأشياء الرئيسية التي يجب ملاحظتها هو
التركيزات العالية للقوات في أماكن مثل
10000 البحرين حيث
يكون لديك  الأسطول الخامس يضم 9000
جندي، 13500 في الكويت، بشكل أساسي حوالي
50000 جندي منتشرين
إما في الشرق الأوسط أو حوله،
وهذا لا يشمل حتى أفراد البحرية
الموجودين في البحر الأحمر وما حوله
وخليج إيدن والخليج العربي إذا
كانوا  نحن واقفون على قدمينا، لدينا 3000 في
الأردن وحتى 800 في سوريا وبالطبع
2500 في العراق، لذا فهذه
مناطق مهمة لنا أن نكون فيها لأن هؤلاء هم
الأشخاص الذين يحمون مصالحنا بالفعل
في هذه المنطقة